c'est une première en france sur le
réseau autoroutier le parc multimodal de
longvilliers est désormais accessible
aux usagers à côté de la sortie 10 de
l'autoroute a10 il est à 40 km de paris
c'est un lieu stratégique
il s'agit en fait de mettre à
disposition des parkings des parkings
gratuits qui permettent aux usagers de
l'autoroute et à ceux du territoire qui
habitent aux environs de ce parc
multimodal de venir sur le parc de garer
leur voiture et ensuite de profiter
d'autres modes de transport qui peuvent
être du covoiturage ou des transports en
bus puisque l'otan euros le bus ensuite
par sur l'autoroute mais c'est pau n'est
pas uniquement un lieu de transit des
partenariats ont été mis en place
et puis on a ancré sous ce projet dans
le territoire en nouant des partenariats
des partenariats avec la gendarmerie qui
est là et qui va pas qui va passer
régulièrement sur ce pôle et pouvoir
rencontrer les juges et des partenariats
également avec les agriculteurs de la
chambre d'agriculture locale qui vont
vendre ici des produits à destination
des usagers
les producteurs locaux seront sur place
plusieurs fois par semaine
mais même s'ils ne sont pas là les
usagers peuvent récupérer les produits
commandés ou acheter directement sur
place grâce à une borne temps des
quasi-fonds lui c'est une vitrine c'est
une façon de faire connaître et de
redonner aux gens de façon faciliter le
réflexe du local mais on leur facilitant
la tâche plus souvent c'est pas simple
il faut aller dans plusieurs fermes il
faut passer beaucoup de temps là on leur
apporte un peu tout ça de façon groupée
le pôle multimodal propose d'autres
services en plus des sanitaires des
machines à café ou encore un espace de
coworking un espace de détente est
présent avec des livres à disposition